now to the two major victories for the
Trump administration in its effort to
crack down an illegal immigration on
Friday President Trump signed what's
described as a safe third country
agreement with Guatemala the agreement
requires migrants who pass through
Guatemala on their way to the US to seek
asylum in Guatemala instead of the US
there's also a ruling regarding mr.
Trump's wall Paula Reid is at the White
House with morning with more on all of
this all the good morning good morning
Jeff an unprecedented number of migrants
have arrived at the southern border this
year and the steal is part of an effort
to reduce that flow of migrants most of
whom are seeking asylum here in the US
the White House and says Guatemala will
provide safety for legitimate asylum
seekers but critics of this deal note
that Guatemala is one of the most
dangerous countries in the world and
they say it's no place to seek refuge we
are doing a very important signing it's
a historic asylum or safe third
agreement between our two countries the
Trump administration signed a deal
Friday with Guatemala requiring migrants
who travel through the country to seek
asylum there instead of in the United
States we're sending a clear message to
human smugglers and traffickers that
your day is over and we're investing in
the future of Guatemala the safety of
migrants and their families will protect
the rights of those with legitimate
claims and will end the widespread abuse
of the system and the crippling crisis
on our border the agreement would
largely impact immigrants coming from
Honduras and El Salvador both countries
plagued by poverty and violence they
also make up about a third of
immigration cases in the u.s. acting
Department of Homeland Security Chief
Kevin McAlinden says anyone who doesn't
follow this new rule will be sent back
they can make a protection claim if they
would like in Guatemala so if they
arrive in the US and not having availed
themselves of that opportunity they'll
be returned to Guatemala the Trump
administration has been pushing for the
agreement even threatening tariffs if
Guatemala did not cooperate in a
statement chairman of the House
Committee on Foreign Affairs eliot engel
called the agreement cruel and immoral
simply put Guatemala is not a safe
country for Refugees and asylum seekers
as the law requires
this deal will likely face legal
challenges as well as logistical ones
the agency in Guatemala responsible for
handling asylum claims tell CBS News it
only has eight employees they usually
handle a few hundred asylum applications
each year but under this new deal they
could potentially have to process
thousands they say they expect to hire
more people but can't confirm Michelle
that's a lot Paula well the Supreme
Court ruled yesterday the president can
use pentagon funds for his border wall
that seems like a big win for the White
House it is a win for the White House
this case is not over it will continue
but as of right now the justices say
that the White House can tap into
billions of dollars of pentagon funds to
begin construction of certain parts of a
border wall at the ACLU which brought
this case says it will ask the lower
courts to expedite this case but the
justices Michelle they did not seem
optimistic that the ACLU will ultimately
be found to prevail in this case even if
they do it's likely these sections of
border wall already have been built
Paula thank you